تحت شعار اول بيت اطلقت وزاره الثقافه
السعوديه الحدث الاول من نوعه في العالم
ولاول مره بنالي الفنون الاسلاميه فهذا
بنالي هو معرض فني كبير وعاده يطلق على
المعارض اللي بتقام كل سنتين ومن كل سنه
بدات اقامه معارض من هذا النوع في
السعوديه او البيت مش بين الفن المعاصر
والثقافه والارث الاسلامي وبيشكل نقطه وصل
بين الماضي
والحاضر عبر اعمال فنيه وتاريخيه متميزه
الحدث انطلق امس في صاله الحجاج الغربيه
بمطار الملك عبد العزيز بجده وبيستمر
لغايه 23 ابريل وسمي باول بيت في اشاره
للكعبه المشرفه او يشارك فيه عدد من
الفنانين السعوديين والعالمين بدون معارض
واثار ومقتنيات بتعرض حتى
للمره الاولى يعني فخلينا من مقر بناء
الداخليه زميلنا مراسل العربيه سلطان اسلم
من ينظم
سلطان ظلمت الدنيا شويه حوالينك بس انا
عارفه انك انت هناك من بدري وتقدر تحكي
لنا عن مشاهداتك
ساره اهلا بكافه المشاهدين بالفعل معرض
بنالي للفنون الاسلاميه نتحدث على معرض
ضخم يقع على مساحه
188,000 متر مربع نتحدث على خمس صلاه عرض
جناحين منها جناح مخصص لمكه وجناح مخصص
للمدينه المنوره تواجد في الصاله واحد قبل
نبدا جولتنا لفت نظري هذا العمل الفني
الملفت جدا نتحدث انه هذا العمل قام به
مهندس الصوت امريكي مسلم عباره عن 19 اذان
من 19 مسجد في 19 دوله مختلفه دمج الاصوات
ليظهر الصوت في تزامل واحد ويقتل واحد
عنده اصول الزائد عند اي واحده من
السماعات هذه ساره هيسمع تونس ونغمه
مختلفه او صوت مختلفه لكن تظهر للعموم
كانها صوت واحد ايضا في داخل هذه الصاله
نتحدث على تفاصيل واعمال مهمه نتحدث اكثر
من 500
فنيه داخل هذا المعرض نتحدث على اكثر من
40 الفنان من مختلف دول العالم وتحديدا من
23 دوله عالميه و18
فنان سعودي هذا المعرض يحمل في طيات وفي
معارضه الخامس وجناحيه عدد كبير من القطع
النادره والفنيه التي تحكي همم فنون
العالم الاسلامي ومجتمعات العالم الاسلامي
قديما هنالك قطعه تعود الى الاف السنين
وقطع نادره واصليه لاول مره تعرض في هذا
المعرض الكبير الذي سوف يستمر لمده ثلاثه
اشهر وسوف يعود مجددا هذا المعرض بعد
عامين في جده ليعرض هذه الفنون وهذه
القطعه النادره هنالك همم اعمال ومجسمات
وقطع وهمم يعني اجنده مكتوبه وكذلك اعمال
اسلاميه مختلفه تحقيق الاسلامي تحكي
المجتمعات الاسلاميه قديما
ملفت هنالك اعداد كبيره من الزوار
والمهتمين بالفنون من مختلف دول العالم
حضروا اليوم او اتجهت بوصلتهم الى جده
للمشاهده هذه العماله لارض الواقع كما
تشاهدون الجميع يعني همم يعني تلفتو هذه
الانظار الصور الناس بتدور المعلومات
الخاصه
بهذا المعرض سبيل المثال هذا عمل فنان من
دوله بنجلاديش يتحدث انه في السابق عندما
كان المسلمين يريدون الذهاب الى مكه لاداء
فريضه الحج كانوا يغرقون في احد الانهار
الضخمه مما جعله يعملون هذه او نموذج مثلا
نماذج
لتثبت بها بشكل كبير وعدم الغرق هذه
القطعه التي تشاهدها في الاعلى هي قطعه
نحاسيه مملوكه للاهل الذين توفوا داخل هذا
النهار انا ذاك في قبل مده طويله ايضا
الاداء المعارض اليوم مساحه كبيره منها
جدا ميزه هذا كانوا تم تصميمه بشكل مناسب
جدا حتى في متعلق بالمؤثرات الصوتيه وحتى
تم توزيع الاضاءات بشكل لا تؤذي همم القطع
الفنيه المعروضه ايضا هنالك عمال تحكي قصص
فنانين وكذلك تحكي نماذج للعيش سابقا في
وقت همم
يعني فيما مضى بسنوات طويله جدا اريد ان
اخذكم ايضا في قسم اخر يحكي عن عمل فني
لفنان همم مغربي كلنا من تراب وضع العديد
من الطوب كما نسميه باللهجه العاميه لكن
بالوان مختلفه همم جدا تحدث انه ليس هنالك
عنصريه في في الاسلام لذلك انه يشاهد هذا
العمل خلال ثواني قادما ننتقل لان المعرض
ما شاء الله حجمه كبير جدا لذلك ان نستطيع
المشي فيه ساعات طويله هيك كان الفعاليات
ورش العمل والجلسات الثقافيه همم
قبل الختام ساره هذا العام الذي كنت تحكي
عنه قبل قليل هو عمل لفنان مغربي صنع هذا
الطوب المختلفه حتى يحكي انك كلنا من طين
او من تراب
سواء السياسيه
احنا بنشكرك يعني على هذه الجوله الاكثر
من رائعه وصراحه ادعوا الناس انهم يروحوا
للمعرض صراحه واضح انه جميل جدا وان شاء
الله كلنا زياره كان معنا من مقارنه جدا
زميلنا مراسل العربيه